Speaker 1: . Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Professor Katherine Liu, who teaches
at University of California, Irvine, and is
also author of the new book Virtue Hoarder's
The Case Against the Professional Managerial
Class. It's so great to have you on today.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
Speaker 1: So there's there's certainly a
narrative I think much of my audience will
be familiar with that is often used in some
populist circles about elites and non elites
or an overclass and an underclass. And one
of the things your book does that's interesting
is you're sort of focusing in on a specific
slice that's smaller than such a simple division,
the managerial class, professional managerial
jewel. Let's start there. What is that? Who's
included in it, et cetera.
Speaker 4: So the professional managerial
class is an intermediary class. A lot of classic
Marxists call it the petty bourgeois because
it's located between the working class, which
is the mass of people without college degrees
now and late capitalism in America and the
capitalists. So this class, uniquely, though,
in the United States, has become really, really
important. Exports, one of the most important
American creations of the postwar period,
the meritocracy. And it basically does the
bidding of capitalism and the capitalist by
producing now we think of as content and ideological
content to justify the really staggering levels
of inequality and exploitation that keep capitalism
going. So discuss our college educated white
collar workers who I like to say do jobs that
don't entail physical damage to their bodies,
that they could actually damage themselves
psychologically and intellectually, which
I think is actually the case. But what they
do is reproduce the ideology of the class
system to make it seem like it's justified
that rich people are rich and it's justified
that the masses are poor and that there are
no universal programs that would actually
create a more equitable society. Now, this
is to say, though, in nineteen seventy seven,
when John and Barbara Ehrenreich wrote about
this class, this class has taken over the
left and progressive liberal organizing spaces.
So it thinks of itself as being on the side
of progress, bright and virtuous and good.
But actually its actions serve only to reproduce
the interests of capitalism.
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is it. So I think many
in the audience may realize that, that when
you tell me is it correct to call this a Marxist
perspective? Yes. Yeah. As a non Marxist myself,
I still think that the analysis has a lot
of very interesting things that that are that
are accurate. And one of the things I was
thinking of during the 20, the rise of the
Tea Party in 2010 was that a lot of the people
that were supporting the Tea Party, they were
definitely never going to benefit from much
of what the Tea Party was advocating for.
Like it wasn't even there was a chance they
would benefit statistically. They just weren't
going to benefit. What I think is interesting
about the managerial class that you're talking
about is that they actually, to some degree,
could benefit from the propping up of the
actual overclass that you describe. And so
there's there actually seems to be if you
want to talk about rationality, it actually
seems more rational to me that they would
prop that system up, whereas it made less
sense with the Tea Party people.
Speaker 4: But I think the Tea Party people
and populists about which I've written in
the past, are animated by a a rage against
the economic system that's left them marginalized.
But what they are but what they support were
free markets, but also the values, traditional
values. And they hated the liberal elites,
the liberal elites who created the crisis
in which they find themselves. And they're
not wrong right now. A lot of them were not
college educated people. They were small business
people would say like crap craftsmen or, you
know, there was like the classic Joe the Plumber
who turned out to be fake. But there were
these this population in America, which I
would say are non college educated people
after World War Two were really hopelessly
rewarded by the redistribution of wealth that
was put into place by both Republican and
Democratic administrations after nineteen
forty five. But since nineteen seventy two,
as you know, the middle and the working classes
have seen their wages stagnate actually go
down. We've seen the social safety net be
destroyed. And so a lot of the actual economic
damage that people. Suffered from in the Tea
Party's setting, and I would say several Trump
supporters had to do with the imposition of
this kind of neoliberal austerity politics
and actually free markets that were engineered
by economists, academics and elites after
nineteen seventy two of both parties. Right.
So what they wanted in the Tea Party was less
government because they thought the government
had created the financial crisis and the government
didn't did. Participate in creating the financial
crisis, but it was Wall Street and financiers
who really produced this crisis and capital
that destroyed a trillion dollars in American
assets like overnight. And there was this
fantasy that that the Tea Party had, that
it was people borrowing and that with bad
credit and and who they were to blame. And
somehow the government and some banks participated
in that. I heard this line repeated to me
by a very wealthy liberal who said, you know,
what caused this crisis? All those people
couldn't afford the houses and everyone wants
a flat screen TV. So, in fact, she's actually
being more rational, although wrong, because
it was actually Goldman Sachs, Morgan Stanley
and AIG that created the crisis, the credit
default swap created with the crisis. But
there's this idea that these poor people overconsuming
who had bad credit and they brought the world
economy to its knees. And so the Tea Party
had that idea and they were all mad at Fox
News, but also MSNBC, CNN watching liberals
had that same idea. So there's actually this
consensus about how poor people caused the
financial crisis that Tea Partiers and liberal
elites shared. PMC liberally shared.
Speaker 1: And yeah, I don't I don't know
if this is I don't know if this this is analogous
or part of or parallel to your analysis. But
to some degree, what I'm hearing you say about
the Tea Party and then also some on the left
is similar to I use the term bamboozling,
but there's probably a different term that
could be used that the populist rhetoric has
succeeded with over the last many years, where
it pulls in people from both left and right
with what are typically different voting patterns
and stated values that that would differ.
But the rhetoric starts to sound similar on
the left and right. But then the solutions
don't match up when you actually ask people,
will, how would you solve this problem?
Speaker 4: But there's a similar level of
irrationality. And what I think is really
insane is that the professional managerial
classes have always prided themselves on being
rational. Right. They're located in the university.
They all went to fancy universities and have
credentials, but they are utterly irrational
right now. And I think that the Russia gate
thing is a really good example of their rationale
that what happened to that. But nobody's supposed
to not trust MSNBC after they made that whole
kerfuffle about something that didn't really
they had no proof for. So that's something
that's in the book, too, is how I show the
PMC. Elites now do not abide by the high liberal
values of either due process or reason and
rational argument in the public sphere and
certainly on the right, people do not believe
in reasoned and rational argument in the public
sphere either. So our the state of our politics
today has a finds ourselves in this position
where nobody wants to defend argument, argument,
reasonable people debating each other, not
agreeing with each other. And the PMC liberals
like to blame this on Fox News and blame this
on extreme right forces. But they are policing
their own boundaries in the same exact way,
and they're demonizing their antagonists to
make them seem like they really don't deserve
to even exist or vote when they and then they
say the Republicans want to suppress the vote.
But I think that there's a lot of contempt
for non college educated Americans, that working
class Americans that's actually in the PMC
itself.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm the part that is less
clear to me is the rush to get peace, because
it seems to me that certainly there were some
people who very early on were setting expectations
that were unreasonable, like Trump's going
to be caught on video planning something with
Putin that was never going to happen. Trump's
going to end up in prison. That was never
going to happen. You know, you go back to
my videos from April of twenty seventeen,
and that's what I said all along. But in great
part, I don't see maybe MSNBC was doing different
things than I, so I don't really watch any
of any MSNBC or that type of stuff. But from
the perspective of this led to not only more
than a dozen indictments, but it actually
found enough wrongdoing to recover more money
than the investigation cost. It is very clear
that Donald Trump was a useful idiot in a
number of different ways. And part of it did
overlap with I don't know that I see that
as the same thing that you see it as necessarily.
Speaker 4: OK, well, I you know, that is a
very reasonable take and I totally appreciate
that. What I think was what I was talking
about more, I guess, is the energy of condemnation
that they were sure was going to lead to an
impeachment. I see. And it works only partially,
but it's so different. I was alive during.
You're probably too young to remember Watergate
when there was bipartisan condemnation of
Nixon, when the work was done to bring in
the Republicans and say something so bad has
happened. Yeah, no illegal has happened that
we have to condemn this person. And the prosecuting
did find wrongdoing, but it didn't actually
create because our politics are so polarized
now, a national consensus.
Speaker 1: But I think that's an indictment
of the Republican Party. I think because when
I see there was a point in Watergate where
the reason there was not impeachment was because
it became clear that Nixon was going down,
if it went that far, because Republicans I
think that the reason it went the way it did
is an indictment on Republicans.
Speaker 4: Now, I absolutely agree. But I
also think there's the core and more, if you
like, of Republicans support popular support
for Trump or right wing popular support for
Trump that is animated by hatred of the professional
managerial class. And the more you have these
liberal talking heads pumping people up about
cultural issues, ignoring actual bread and
butter, economic issues are suffering the
majority of Americans, the more you will have
this label of hypocrisy being thrown at liberal
elites and this idea also that there are worthy
people to help and unworthy people to help.
That is usually a Republican and right wing
talking point. But the liberal elite PMC has
actually done this completely, like there
are good poor people and there are bad working
class people and working to give all of the
moral iniquity to the other side. Well, and
not and they do not see their complicity and
actually bring us to a state where the country
is so polarized and so divided and animated
by these class antagonisms and hatreds that
should be talked about rationally. They can't
do that, though, because that would mean that
they will not saintly in some way. I think
it is like tried to cloak itself in a kind
of saintly identity that always has to put
itself on the right side of things. Let's
look at the state of California. We have an
incredible homeless problem that is generated
by regulations on housing and land use in
the state, the PMC here in the state, they
rule the democratic elites have supermajorities
in everything and every legislative branch
in this state, and yet they can only put up
Black Lives Matter sign in. Their yards, and
they refused to have lower income housing
built in their neighborhoods or homeless shelters
built in their neighborhoods or even create
higher density housing so that we're not living
in suburban enclave suburban hell. Right.
This this this state, with its veneer of liberalism
and its preachiness about tolerance, has actually
created this kind of dystopia of inequality.
But they don't really actually want to solve
the look at the San Francisco school board.
They stop this now. But rather than asking
for funding to get schools open in the correct
way, supporting teachers and students, they
wanted to rename San Francisco public schools.
Forty four of them, one of them named after
Abraham Lincoln because of the racism of the
past me just infuriates me so much because,
first of all, I. I don't like Dianne Feinstein.
I don't think she should have a school named
after her. But if you just go after these
cosmetic things and then you say like people
who are from the past, like Lincoln, were
racist, what the PMC there is saying is everyone
who came before us are racist. We're enlightened,
and we're going to create a cosmetic, superficial
veneer of tolerance and anti-racism, ignoring
all of the structural economic inequalities
that has made the San Francisco school system
majority minority African-American, Latinos
and Asian American working class people use
that public school system, the wealthy elites
of all the mostly white, but some of them
Asians, some of them African American, some
of them are Latino. They send their kids to
private schools. And this is what has happened
in every city in the country, is this kind
of lip service to public education and this
undermining of public goods so that the upper
tier of the PMC can enjoy privatized education
and everyone else is left with poor quality
mass education that nevertheless has a veneer
of tolerance. And that's a great strategy
for virtue, holding and reproducing economic
inequality.
Speaker 1: So in the very limited time we
have left, I want to get your thoughts on
how we've talked about this issue of the cultural
fights that, you know, particularly in the
Trump era. The right is not they're not even
pretending to be about policy anymore. It's
it's Dr. Seuss, it's council culture, etc.,
etc.. As a strategic calculation, should the
left fight these cultural issues or should
they just ignore them and focus on policy
or something else?
Speaker 4: Well, the left doesn't have it
doesn't have much of a commitment to freedom
of speech right now. So I think if the left
fights these issues, I'm not sure what they're
going to actually be standing on because they
actually don't want Dr. Seuss books to be
reproduced. Those books are really problematic
in many ways, but also a lot of people enjoyed
those books. I enjoyed those books for my
kids and my kid. And so I. I feel like the
culture war aspect of American politics serves
elites on both sides of the party. So it doesn't
I guess
Speaker 1: the reason I think it serves the
right more is that the left has a package
right now when it comes to infrastructure,
foreign policy, taxation pandemic that's absent
from a lot of the the new right. So it strikes
me that it would be better for the left to
focus on that.
Speaker 4: The policies I always someone who's
for focusing on economic material issues.
OK, that is the bottom line. What is who benefits,
who doesn't benefit, remain focused on the
economics that's, I think, always going to
work much better and actually deliver for
people, not just focus on economic policies
that will create more redistributive redistribution
of wealth, but really deliver. I think the
vaccine is a sign that there can be publicly
funded health initiatives. And you should
focus on that. We should focus on creating
strong infrastructure within public health,
universal health care, universal quality child
care, all of these bread and butter issues
that people need in their lives desperately
right now. And if you can produce that, then
you can produce a sense of the collective.
You can produce a sense of progressive liberal
policies that work for people. Yes. And so
in that sense, they should not take the bait
left to not take the bait on the cultural
issues. They should absolutely deflect. And
I and I've had my I've been an agnostic on
Biden, but I do feel like he's much more progressive
than Obama and that his stimulus package is
be something that is executed with the greatest
fervor and authority. And here's one thing
I'm going to end with is that I'm not playing
the PM the blame game where I say, OK, the
PMC, they're all bad. No, we need good professionals,
can't have infrastructural reconstruction
of this country without return to the professional
standards of both like stockbroking or researching
universities or policy making and think tanks.
That is shielded from the market right now.
All of these knowledge workers are so driven
by profit and we need to go back to nonmarket
professional standards of being. And that's,
I think, something we often lose track of
in the left. And we think like anybody who
is a bureaucrat is bad. How are you going
to spend one point nine trillion dollars correctly
or. Well, without a good functioning bureaucracy,
good functioning government? That's why I
have no patience for the anarcho leftists.
Speaker 1: Yes, you and me both. You and me
both. The book is Virtue Hoarder's The Case
Against the Professional Managerial Class.
We've been speaking, of course, with the book's
author, Professor Katherine Lou. So great
to have you on today.
Speaker 4: Thank you, David. Thank you so
much.